good afternoon everyone I'm Brian
Thompson I am very proud to be the mayor
of Brunswick Georgia and I'm even more
proud to be able to introduce our
hometown boy to you this evening Bob
dart young man that's gone out and done
good he's come back we're glad to have
him a couple of things here at the
beginning this is promenade night here
in historic downtown Brunswick almost
all the shops are staying open late not
only are they giving away free food most
of them are giving away free glasses of
wine now I know y'all are going to be
quiet and respectful you're going to
turn your cell phones off you're not
going to take flash photographs and when
we get to the Q&A at the end we asked if
you would if you'll raise your hand just
like your mom and your first grade
teacher taught you to do raise your hand
so you can be called on and that'll work
out great now the people that are
wandered up down the street drinking the
wine when they come in it could get a
little rowdy or later on but that's all
right i'm sure you'll set a good example
for them and they'll fall right in line
when they get in here with us so it is
my pleasure to introduce again Bob dart
bob was born and raised here in
Brunswick Glynn County graduated from
Glynn Academy married his high school
his high school sweet sweet heart and
have two wonderful children live up in
Virginia right now Bob graduated from
FSU in 1968 was drafted into the army
worked as a combat correspondent during
Vietnam for stars and stripes God got
through that did extremely well with
that came back out his master's degree
in journalism from georgia state or
university of georgia pardon me and
worked for a while for the Atlanta
Journal in Constitution and then joined
the Cox Washington bureau in 1983 he has
been involved in conflicts around the
world man-made disasters natural
disasters political campaigns you name
it he's been involved he's covered it
the Iraq invasion
he has one heck of a lot of experience
and I talked to one of his former
employers Jim sitting here in the front
said the only reporter ever had it
didn't have to explain everything to and
even years later he's proud of that his
new book down home dispatches from Dixie
certainly some stories from the area
here which we always appreciate we like
the PR I like it especially as the mayor
I collect historic Brunswick memorabilia
and I was going through some of my items
that I have and I came across this and
as way of introduction I want to present
this to Bob as he steps forward here but
it's just a postcard from 1907 many of
you will recognize this this is Lanier's
oak marshes of Glen and on the back it
tells a little bit of a story just a
little teaser of a story it's addressed
to a miss Stella leg in Calhoun Georgia
and the messages hello Stella why don't
you write to me I haven't heard from you
in such a long time please answer soon
lovingly johnny now 2 perhaps entice her
further to write on the front and I
think this is why it's relevant to Bob
dart on the front he's written at the
bottom nice little scene nice to come
visit me here at the bottom it says this
is near misses darts the fortune teller
so with that I'd like to present this on
behalf of the mayor and commissioned to
bob guard his ancestor
and welcome home Thank You mayor and
thank all of y'all for coming out to see
this grading hometown boy I've been a
long time since anybody introduced me as
a young man Glynn County is and always
will be down home to me of course as it
has been for generations of darts it's
gratifying and humbling to see so many
familiar faces you all have to bear with
me a bit because this is my first
reading as an author but I've been all
my adult life is a reporter it's a
calling that's come in for some
criticism in recent years the New York
Times had to admit that Jayson Blair one
of its reporters had flat-out fabricated
stories Stephen Blass was so bold and
his false reporting for the New Republic
that they made a movie about it call
shattered glass when I hear about such
liars and print I always have one
reaction they must have much better
imaginations than I do I could never
make up better stories and the true ones
have happened upon for instance the
first national political convention i
covered was when the Democrats met in
san francisco in 1984 and nominated
Walter Mondale for president in San
Francisco as it has been at nearly every
political convention since my assignment
was to cover protest and pardons yes I
get paid to go to parties it's a tough
job but somebody has to do it anyway
just about every protest and every party
of that convention was attended by a
transvestite who was the size of a
Georgia Bulldog offensive tackle and who
wore nun's habit with a black miniskirt
this huge drag queen called himself or
herself sister boom boom of the order of
perpetual indulgence
she or he was a local politician with a
none of the above party that's en un I
think I mentioned this was in San
Francisco I could not have made up
sister boom boom that same summer the
Republicans had their convention in
dallas inama nominated Ronald Reagan for
a second term I covered a party for
black Republicans a select group then
and now at Southfork the ranch where the
TV show Dallas originated I drove a
rental car up that long road to the big
house that you saw in the opening of
each episode there was a pavilion in the
car I mean in the yard where Dallas
Cowboy Cheerleaders were handing out
yellow roses to african-american
Republicans and an instructor was
teaching them to dance the cotton eyed
Joe I marveled at this scene from beside
the pool where miss Ella used to have
breakfast that same Republican
convention I went to a party at the
ranch of Bunker hunt he was a
conservative fundraiser and a
multi-billionaire until he tried to
corner the world silver market they had
an actual rodeo of this party and guests
could talk take hot air balloon rides
but what I remember most is seeing the
Reverend Jerry Falwell wearing a
ten-gallon hat and sitting astride a
longhorn steer while people to kiss
picked you I can't make up stuff like
that
and why would I try for the past 30 plus
years I've written about what I've
actually seen and tasted and heard and
smelled and experienced that's the gist
of my book it's a collection of true
stories about my native South that are
too good for me to have made up my first
story that middle read problem is about
Junior samples I'm not sure how many of
y'all remember junior but this was
Junior samples I spent a day at his
house in [ __ ] Georgia in 1981 at the
time he was a star of E hall he died in
1983 and this could well be the first
time that anyone has ever talked about
Junior samples on c-span anyway I'd like
to read some from my chapter of my visit
with jr. jr. was a sawmill man sometimes
other times he was a pope woodsman or a
carpenter or a moonshiner I made liquor
in every branch in Forsyth County and a
few chicken coops too he said mostly
though junior was that fun-loving breed
of southern ER called a good old boy by
his buddies but call no count by their
lives my old lady was working making a
living the neighbors all tended to my
business so I just hunted and fished
mostly he recalled and that's the way it
should have been to like the Indians
then in 1987 an official from the
Georgia Game and Fish Commission heard a
radio report that one Junior samples had
caught a world record bass actually
juniors brother Monroe had found the
fish a saltwater group err on the side
of the highway
apparently it had been tossed out by a
fisherman passing through Forsyth County
when his way home from the coast jr. cut
off the fish's head and proclaimed the
body was a bass he had caught when the
game and fish fellow reached Forsyth
County he found jr. sitting on his front
porch nipping on his second pain of the
day he said he'd come up after a story
bout that fish I didn't think he was
going to leave so I went and drunk me
another drink and told him one what
followed was only one of those only in
American success stories juniors fish
joy was taped although it was quickly
exposed to the hoax the telling event
was so funny that a record was made in
Nashville jr. became a comedian working
little clubs across the south eventually
performing at the Grand Ole Opry he said
things funny more than he said funny
things but I didn't get on hee haw
because of that fish story he stressed I
had to take a test for it like everyone
else done was in 1969 the new hee haw
program sort of a cornpone version of
laugh-in offered to pay him either $73
or $93 to audition he didn't remember
which so he went to Nashville a writer
gave him a card with his lines to read
jr. said he couldn't I told him to give
me some four-letter words to read they
said I couldn't say no dirty wars on TV
but I told them i meant words like they
or what
I could read those words but not the big
ones on that card Junior said the writer
told him to just read what he thought
the words on the card worked I did and
it just broke him up a star was born
shortly thereafter Junior samples moved
his family to the nice brick house off
setting down road and settled into the
good life nowadays he goes to Nashville
twice a year for two weeks each trip to
take P hall for those four weeks work
which consists mostly of standing in a
fake corn field wearing bib overalls and
a t-shirt and flubbing lines on camera
he has paid about thirty thousand
dollars I think the Lord done it he said
once again I can't make up stuff like
that Junior samples like many of the
colorful characters I've encountered
over the decades lived a story too
unbelievable to have been fiction I
mentioned the sea Spanish here recording
my first reading as an author in my
hometown in a room full of relatives and
old friends my wife sherry is here her
mother Clyde Rogers the world's best
mother-in-law my brothers Dylan dawn we
both still little st. Simons Island I
only wish my mom and daddy Oakland
Robert dart could have lived who shared
this day with us I'm grateful to
everyone who came out to see me under
those who are put it on TV it's amazing
I have to agree with the Junior samples
on this I think the Lord done it having
been based in Washington DC for the past
25 years I do have some politics in
down-home one chapter deals with a
sophisticated discourse on public
affairs found in the lyrics of country
music songs it's called the politics of
music Road reporting on this story took
me to Nashville to an upstairs room it
took sees orchid lounge to seize back
door is located across an alley from the
back stage two
or at the Ryman Auditorium the Ryman was
hung with the Grand Ole Opry for half a
century before off real and opened
country music stars from Hank Williams
to Willie Nelson have ducked into
Tiffany's for a drink or two between
acts I went there to talk to a group
called the Music Row Democrats now the
conventional wisdom is that liberals and
Nashville's country music industry or
about as plentiful and popular as
conservatives are in Hollywood's movie
industry and the conventional wisdom may
be right but there are some liberals on
Music Row and they had a sad song to
sing so to speak one of the Music Row
Democrats America sees was Bobby
Braddock a country music hall of fame
songwriter he co-wrote what is widely
considered to be the best country music
song of all time he stopped loving her
today sung by George Jones he also wrote
a bird from my book Bobby and some
others let me listen to some pretty good
country music songs the child never hear
on the radio they said it was because of
the political bent of the lyrics one is
called i'm taking my country back and
was recorded by an ad hoc group called
honky talkers for truth the chorus goes
i'm taking my country back son you ain't
been doing her right well I've been
watching you and I don't like I even
treating my stars and strikes you took
our jobs and sent them overseas now we
owe billions to the Red Chinese you blew
the budget and you botched Iraq so I'm
taking my country back now the music
Road Democrats argued that this is a
song with a good hook and a catchy tune
it's got those classic double levels of
meeting country meaning nation and
country meaning music son as a reference
to the second president Bush but it
never got played on the radio meanwhile
from the other side of the political
spectrum darryl worley got a lot of
airplay for his song have you forgotten
here's the opening stanza I hear people
saying we don't need this war
I say there are some things worth
fighting for what about our freedom and
this piece of ground we didn't get to
keep them by backing down they say we
don't realize the mess we're getting in
before you start preaching let me ask
you this my friend have you forgotten
about bin Laden I love country music by
the one so in reporting on this trip I
managed to make two trips to Nashville
and to go to the Ryman and the Bluebird
Cafe to hear singer-songwriters again I
came away with a true story I couldn't
make up and in this one all the
characters were better writers than I
was let me give you one more example
this is a song by James McMurtry his
father Larry McMurtry wrote Lonesome
Dove and many other Texas novels he's
likely never heard this on the radio
that big old building was a textile mill
they fit our kids and it paid our bills
but they turned us out and they closed
the doors we can't make it here anymore
now i'm stuck in short shirts at the
walmart store just like the ones we made
before except this one came from
singapore i guess we can't make it here
anymore now you might support free trade
or you might think NAFTA is the worst
thing to happen to America since
Prohibition but these lyrics from
Nashville make a case that protest songs
didn't die in the 60s and country music
is about more than tears in my beer
because she done me wrong turning a few
pages in my book from Nashville we
reached the rugged mountainous region
where Tennessee Virginia and West
Virginia and Kentucky all sort of come
together this is where the santa train
rumbles once a year I've managed to
write it twice I want to read a bit to
my book about those trips
as it has for over half a century the
sound of special rolled out of Shelby
yard about sunrise on the Saturday
before Thanksgiving it whistles past
Marrowbone and splash damn rumbles
through the coal fields and hollows
crosses over copper creek trestles and
under sandy ridge tunnel creeks pass
memorable miles of abandoned appliances
rusted house trailers and resilient
smiles since nineteen forty-three the
Santa special has taken toys and closed
and candy and other presents to the
children of Appalachia older folks along
the way recall how was the only
Christmas they had during hard times
nowadays coal miners are pretty well
paid but still thousands of people come
out and stand beside the tracks every
year for the nostalgia as well as the
goodies
holding her grandson in Elkhorn City the
vine Campbell was hit in the forehead by
a hard edge of a flying little golden
book two nurses rush from the train to
watch the blood from her face and dress
the cut meanwhile Santa's helpers kept
the grandson happy with gifts away from
the settlements though family stood in
isolated spots all along the route and
waved passing trains a dozen kids are
coming up on the left to spotter would
yell on the platform behind the caboose
Santa and helpers will throw out stuffed
animals moon pies Barbie dolls Hershey
bars or any of a myriad of other goodies
on the rail bed waving and shouting
Merry Christmas as the Train sped away
the children will scramble onto the
tracks and pick up their presents if I
hadn't been there I never would have
known about that flying little golden
book that's why I've loved my job for so
long being there when it happens that's
the joy and journalism down-home Texas
scores of places I've been in the South
New Orleans and the days and months
after katrina virginia tech in the hours
after the shooting and to douglas
georgia on a summer sunday in 1984 a
union of my momma side of the family
brother James require of the Macedonia
Church of God gives lengthy thanks for
the bountiful food and family now
assembled the amens are still echoing as
people start down the long line to load
their plates there's fried chicken home
cured ham smoked turkey roast beef in
the aforementioned barbecue and dressing
biscuits squash lady finger peas collard
greens and fresh vegetables an
assortment of casseroles homemade
pickles and relishes potato salad
deviled eggs chicken and dumplings
sliced tomatoes and cucumbers Brunswick
stew and a myriad of other dishes
regretfully neglected because of the
necessity of keeping the line moving
there are a well-placed igloo coolers of
iced tea and a separate table for cakes
and pies and custards despite the dire
predictions of some of the chefs the
food is eaten with enthusiasm and
dispatching without discrimination there
are no speeches to interrupt the second
helpings or the thirds oratory is not a
Clemmie straight it's not long before
folks are pushing back their chairs from
the tables the women gossip as they
clean up the children run off to play
some more the men seek out the scant
shade of Jack pines where they whittle
and smoke and shoot families are already
loading up and heading out when a
photographer tries to arrange the whole
a group shot of the whole bunch other
problems have set in the babies are
crying for their naps the full belly
dole men are ready to lie down on the
couch children are tired and cross and
Mama's are in no mood process daddy's
dread the long drives home the farewell
is as familiar as the family as old as
the region itself y'all come see us now
before I wind up here I want to thank my
publisher southern line books of Madison
and cover designers Burton bird of Macon
I was up in Washington and they got the
book done down in Georgia but hopefully
it won't be long before sherry and I are
back in Georgia to this is home there
are a bunch of darts in Glen County both
black and white and we all share a
lineage to the sons of Ravana start the
founder of Brunswick I'll conclude with
a little bit of family history it was
written from st. Simons Island and 2005
the bones of sour start rests between
but excuse me the bones of Cyrus start
rest beneath the grayish green waters
off this blessed barrier I'll my
great-great-great grandfather was a
medical doctor and the quarantine
officer for the port and the decades
following the American Revolution in
1817 he drowned at the age of 53 when
his row boat capsized on the way to
expect a ship's crew for communicable
diseases he was accompanied by his young
son or banos who managed to swim safely
ashore otherwise I would not be here to
chronicle this saga of a family in black
and white sirens could not have imagined
the diversity of descendants who
gathered here on Patriot's Day to honor
the patriarch of Dixie's branch of the
dark family tree folks say there's a
place that there's a sense of place in
the soul of southern families for me
that sense of place centers on Glenn
County the home of my forebearers and
the sight of the marshes and beaches
where I grew up but there are as many
such home places as there are multi-hued
families throughout the south where
people different in many ways can come
together to explore their shared
ancestry in this region so long troubled
by issues of race many of us really our
brothers and sisters under our skins
okay I'll have any questions wait for
him to the boom in front of you yes mr.
Bentley good there's the blue okay I've
got a long start so that other people
can think of questions it actually make
more sense when Bob and I work together
we ran into a lot of things I was in
race riots that's scary we've had
reporters who was shot cliff Krause and
Reagan wars in the Central America there
were people who got in trouble in
various parts of the world and there
were scary times Jill Albright was our
chief foreign correspondent and I was at
the Washington bureau what said the most
frightening thing in his life was while
dresses the Mujahideen in Afghanistan in
the early 1980s he was pulled out of his
tent by the guys he was hiding out with
and they said there's a row of Soviet
tanks coming down the next Ridge over
there Joe scariest moment was the sound
of the shutter crashing open when he
tried to take a picture of the Soviet
tanks it was in his mind it was the
loudest sound he had ever heard and my
question is while you were running
around on the company buddy having all
these adventures did you ever get in to
a situation where you felt a little
nervous or scared or where you started
looking for the back door before today
[Laughter]
I went to a rock I embedded with an
infantry division and rode in the back
of a humvee during during up I guess
when we were winning the war pretty yes
during the chakan da lera we were shot
at but I never really felt scared one of
the interesting things that I was
fighting with all these 19 year old
soldiers these are you know young young
kids they never had to sleep and we went
three weeks without a bath and I would
take off my shirt we would like wash off
with baby wipes and I was take off my
shirt and all these 19 year-old buff
young guys would say put it on Bob are
we going to look like that when we get
old the others yes ma'am
books in you will you be riding Norfolk
I hope to I hope to sell enough of this
book to retire and move down the same
silence and write more books so tell
your friends yes part I hear you mention
your mother because she would be so very
proud today and I'm because she told
your potential early in your life well
my Florence is one of my mother's best
friends for 50 years I lived in my
neighborhood growing up and my mother
did teach me I could read well before I
started school I can remember the first
day when they brought out the little
books and they said you know this is
Dick and Jane or whatever and I but I
raised my anise that that's dick that's
Jane a spot that's Sally that's fluff I
can imagine the teacher said oh my god
what am I got ticklish this what yes
maybe I should bring this one up but do
you remember they little boy who drowned
when all of you were down oh yes I do
the pond on a good Avenue yes there was
a upon behind our house is behind the
Anchorage in and Glen my friend and
Florence's son had gone over to see my
brothers who were fishing over there
actually we needed to borrow money from
them to go to the movie ever what was
playing was Butterfield 8 and I when we
got over there there was a little ol boy
who was on the other side well this was
in the winter and it was cold and he
jumped in the pool everything to like
and he was swimming around and we didn't
seem any more and we went over there and
we looked around and we got scared so we
jumped in the water and tried tried to
save him we never could find him and
then they called the fire department and
they drugged the bottom and drug him out
of
the water and we actually got the money
I went to the movie and then got kicked
out because we were talking too much
telling other people about his story yes
education well how long at what point
did these stories become a book in your
mind were you writing always well I was
writing a you know they've all been
ready and I just hated the thought of
them all sitting in a computer database
and no one ever able to see them and it
was easier to write this kind of a book
than it was to make up all news stories
and so I had them and yes and I always
wanted to be had to assemble my books
it's also you know if no one bought any
i figured i would have them for future
generations with darts and they're going
to pay what great-great-grandfather part
did yes yes how would you describe the
south as a region compared to other
regions because i mean this is a
regional book these are regional stories
and obviously you've been everywhere
worked everywhere and have lots of
stories about other regions so what
description would you give all right
except southerners are friendlier nicer
the food is better and there are better
storytellers I think my stories are
mostly other people telling stories and
I just write down what they read like
Junior samples and I think there's sort
of an innate ability in the cell to tell
stories and it makes my job a lot easier
okay
because the jaws retail hear about our
we listen to that yes my video Kathy
interesting to finish the book and read
how many stories overlap from what Bill
told our children growing up a Victorian
three little boys and so it'll be fun to
see what you told your children and what
he told our children yeah there are
three little boys toys or me and my
brothers bill and Don growing up and we
ended up telling our children the three
little boys stories there's one three
little boys story when we were we used
to have wars I guess they still do when
you're a little child and we are having
a war with a billy goat boys and we
covered ourselves up with big piles of
moss and crawl down the alley to ambush
the Billy Goat voice and my children
love it I said didn't think you think
they would notice this moving pile of
ball what our parents got onto us
because didn't you know there were red
bugs in law and we're itching from weeks
afterward yes generous stories come from
all over the south and with the
cosmopolitan or all the big cities
creeping in on the rural areas do you
think the south is diminishing and do
you think that our stories will be fewer
and far between I don't know there is
homogeneous a shin of the south is
people you know move to the cities and
one of my stories is about my personal
some people call it a midlife crisis in
the perspective section when i wrote a
about whether or not i thought i should
be in a small southern town rather than
Washington but yeah I think you're right
i think some of the flavor of the south
is it will be diminished as people leave
and it's sort of sad that they have to
leave because there are no jobs and
that's what counts like brunswick and
other places need or jobs for people
be able to stay there when they grow up
Bill Brown I believe you you mentioned
battle they had finally big fellows
barber yes sir hey when he moved off of
the 1300 block I rented him the space
right over here the other flat of this
building and he got by here till he died
he was a great fellow yes I was story
about battle battle plus an
african-american he was back during the
segregation era battle was the only
black businessman in downtown Bruntlett
and the barbershop was called Floyd's
battle was for the later generation it
started somewhere around the turn of the
century Floyd was long gone before I got
there but generations of boys in
Brunswick had their hair cut at Floyds
it was it was quite a place for some
reason there was a statue of the Venus
de Milo in the front window and that was
our exposure to art I guess but the
other exposure to us was that once we
got to be 11 or 12 battle would slip us
a Playboy magazine to look at while they
were a lady and that kept us coming back
and battle he was also a great barber
mr. Bentley again what are the markets
that you've got available to you to
write identity storytelling and an
enjoyable reading what are the markets
are there out there magazines and some I
guess I don't know newspapers as mr.
Bentley and I both know Jim was my
editor in atlanta and in Washington
later or not going through good times
these days and I'm afraid that many of
these stories would not get in today's
papers they sort of changed or shorter
they're more homogenized and so I'm
grateful that I came along when I did
and I'm ready to leave now so there
aren't as many markets for writers
anymore my son is a lawyer and wants to
be a novelist and I'm I'm hoping he
finds something anybody else well I want
to thank you all for coming out I've
enjoyed this hasn't been nearly as bad
as I thought it would be
yeah thank you for coming
[Applause]